this is sprouts cool science produced by
minute videos teaching technique number
one how do I retain my students attention
research suggests that students attention
reduces dramatically about fifteen minutes into
class within 30 minutes it is often as low as
20% of the original level and after forty-five
minutes it's almost entirely gone given that we
spend up to 12 years in school it becomes
clear how important it is to increase the
time where your students actually pay attention
one method to fight boredom and keep attention
high is to reduce the session length you can
break them up into segments with small breaks
in between even if that does not mean students
get back to the initial high studies show that
whenever a new section begins attention is
lifted dramatically before it drops again a
history teacher for example could break up
Columbus's voyage over the ocean into four
chunks with short one-minute breaks in between
in the first 20 minutes the teacher could tell
the story about the voyage the next 15 minutes
students could discuss in groups what could have
been dangerous about sailing during these days
then each group could present their discoveries
for another 15 minutes in the last segment the
teacher could complete the students findings
and bring them in context with the actual risks
of Columbus's expedition please use the comments
section below to let us know what you think if
you are a student tell us if the method improves
your learning if you are a teacher share with
us how you apply it in class we're releasing
updates regularly so don't forget to subscribe
and like us on Facebook thank you for watching